اهلا بكم مشاهدينا مجددا نواصل معكم هذه
التغطيه المباشره عبر شاشه العربيه
للمقاطعه المتفجر في السودان منذ اربعه
ايام بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع ويشهد محيط القياده العامه للجيش
السوداني في هذه الاثناء بالعاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم اطلاق نار متواصل بين
الجانبي الجانبين كما يسمع ديونفجار عنيف
جدا وانفجارات في وقت سابق افاد مراسل
العربيه بان عشرات الطلاب ما زالوا
محتجزين داخل جامعه الخرطوم رئيس وفد
الهلال الاحمر وكذلك وفد الصليب الاحمر
الدولي قال انه من المستحيل تقريبا تقديم
الخدمات الانسانيه في العاصمه ما نقابه
الاطباء التي كشفت عن مقتل 144 على الاقل
حتى الان فقد وجهت عبر العربيه لذا انا
عاجلا لتوفير ممرات امنه وامدادات بالمياه
والوقود للمستشفيات الداخليه السودانيه
واصدرت قرارا بانهاء انتداب ضباط الشرطه
بقوات الدعم السليم خارج العاصمه الخرطوم
اعلن الجيش السوداني السيطره على الاوضاع
في نيالا في ولايه جنوب دارفور مشيرا الى
ان الدعم السريع يستعد لاستقبال مساعدات
عسكريه في مطار مروي وزاره الخرجات
السودانيه طالبت من جهتها الامم المتحده
بادانه قوات الدعم السريع لانتشارها داخل
احياء سكنيه مصر للطيران اعلنت في سياق
هذا التوتر المتزايد وفق رحلاتها الجويه
من والى الخرطوم حتى يشعر اخر
دراسه كاميرا العربيه لحظه سقوط قذائف في
محيط القياده العامه للجيش السوداني ما
تسبب في دوي انفجار هائل وارتفاع اعمده
دخان كثيفه بان هناك مجموعات مسلحه
متواجده في الخرطوم ربما وغيرها يتم
الحديث ربما عن اوكر
اقصد ان هناك مجموعات مسلحه متواجده في
الخرطوم ربما وغيرها يتم الحديث ربما عن
اوكر
اقصد انه هناك مجموعات فقد حضرت ايضا لجنه
اطباء السودان من ارتفاع معدل القتلى
والمصابين من المدنيين مع استمرار شراسه
المعارك بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع ولفت التقرير اللجنه الى صعوبه
اجلاء وحصر عدد القتلى والمصابين بالاضافه
الى العالق اللجنه قالت عددا من
المستشفيات توقفت عن تقديم خدماتها اثر
التعرضها للقصب وانقطاع الكهرباء وشح
الامدادات كما رفض التقرير استغلال
العناصر المتحاربه للامدادات والمعونات
الطبيه
ركائزه مع اعتبرته جريمه انسانيه واخلاقيه
اللجنه ايضا دانت الحرب الراهنه وناشدت
المتقاتلين بفتح امراه امنه لمعالجه
المرضى والمصابين وايصال المخزونات
الغذائيه والطبيه لمستحقيه
معكم في متابعه وتغطيه ايضا مستمره
لتطورات الاحداث الان في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم مع ارتفاع وتصاعد حده
المواجهات والمشتباكات بين قوات الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع في اكثر من منطقه في
العاصمه السودانيه الان وحسب الاخبار
العاجله قوات الدعم السريع تدعو المجتمع
الدولي الى عدم التعامل مع بيانات
الخارجيه السودانيه
مجددا تنضم الينا في استديوهاتنا من
الرياض مدينه مكتب العربيه في الخرطوم
لينا يعقوب لينا اهلا وسهلا بك معنا اولا
نقرا في اخر التطورات والمستجدات وخاصه
المناشده الان من قوات الدعم السريعه
للمجتمع الدولي بعدم التعامل مع بيانات
الخارجيه السودانيه ماذا يمكن ان نقرا في
هذا السياق طبعا الدعم السريع يستخدم كل
الوسائل المتاحه لكسب المجتمع الدولي لكسب
مواقف دوليه بالامس ايضا ناشده المجتمع
الدولي مناشدات مختلفه اذا الامر يتطور
بالنسبه للدعم السريع ولكن طبعا للسودان
دوله ومؤسسات من بينها وزاره الخارجيه من
بينها وزاره الصحه التي تصدر البيانات
لا يعقل ان لا يتم التعامل في هذه اللحظات
مع المؤسسات الرسميه
خريطه المواجهات الان
تتسع ربما تشهد ايضا زياده في المناطق
التي تدخل في هذه المواجهات في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم تقييم الوضع الان من
هذا البعجه ولا من البعد العسكري كيف يمكن
قراءته ايضا ليله في ظل الانباء المتواتره
التصاعد حده الاشتباك نعم خالد حده
الاشتباكات موجوده في منطقه بحري محيط
القياده في مناطق في وسط الخرطوم في مناطق
اخرى هذا يشير بصوره واضحه الى ان
الاشتباكات مستمره حتى اليوم الرابع على
التوالي في الخط دخلت حالات انسانيه ولابد
ان نشير الى ان هناك تلاميذ كانوا محتجزين
داخل مدرسه وهناك طلاب كانوا موجودين داخل
جامعات قبل قليل تحدث احد الطلاب بان
الجيش قام
بحمايه واجلاء الى هؤلاء الطلاب الى
اماكنهم خطوره هذا الامر بان التلاميذ
حينما يكون متواجدين في مدرسه هذا يعني
الاعتماد على ما هو موجود في المدرسه وما
هو في موجود في المدرسه يمكن ان يكفيهم
ليوم واحد ونحن نعلم اننا الان في شهر
رمضان وشهر الصيام هناك عوائق كثيره الان
تحيط بكل العالقين من بينها نقص الغذاء
انقطاع الكهرباء انقطاع المياه فضلا عن
وجود حالات صحيه تحتاج الخروج كل هذه
الاوضاع الانسانيه الان تشير بصوره واضحه
الى استمرار تداعيات الحرب على الشارع
السوداني
المعارك وحسب هذه التطورات في مجريات
الاحداث دخول المناطق اخرى ايضا جديده في
هذه الاشتباكات تجعلون يعني نفكر في
مالاتها وفي افق الان هذه المعارك وهذه
الحرب الى اي مدى يمكن
ان تدوم برايك من خلال هذه الانباء
المتواتره
واعلنوه الجيش بانه اقترب من حسم المعركه
ورغم ما اعلنه الدعم السريع امس لكن يبدو
ان هذا الامر قد يطول لماذا اولا لاعداد
قوات الدعم السريع اعداد قوات الدعم
السريع لا يستهم بها هي عشرات الالاف
موجوده في العاصمه الخرطوم وفي ولايه
السودانيه مهما كان للجيش من مقدرات
محاوله التغلب على كل هذه الاعداد سيستغرق
وقتا صحيحا الجيش قال انه الان اقترب من
حسب المعركه ولكن يبدو واضحا ان هذا الامر
سيطول وسيستمر خاصه ان الدعم السريع قد
يحول ايضا طريقه المعارك الى تكتيك اخر
بان لا يحارب بزيه مثلا الرسمي مع الجيش
بان تكون في يديه ايضا اسلحه يحارب فيها
من داخل ربما مناطق سكنيه كل هذه الامور
تشير الى ان استمرار الحرب سيطول نتابع
الان هذه الصور التي وردتنا قبل قليل وهي
المشاهد
لانتشار الجيش السوداني في بعض
المناطق وشوارع في العاصمه السودانيه في
اي مناطق هذه لنا
هل يمكن تحديد المنطقه
متاكده حتى اللحظه لا يظهر معلم واضح في
هذا الشارع
الان هذه المدرعات هذه الاليات التابعه
للجيش السوداني وهي تتحرك ربما في احدى
المناطق من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
في اشاره واضحه ربما الى اتساع رقعه
المواجهات والاشتباكات التي تشهدها مناطق
متفرقه من العاصمه السوداني
ايضا رقعه تمدد الجيش لانني ذكرت قبل قليل
ان الدعم السريع منتشر في عدد من الشوارع
في العاصمه
فحركه الجيش هذا يدل ويشير الى ان الجيش
الان يعني يتحرك في عدد من المناطق وعدد
من الشوارع لابعاد الدعم السريع عن مناطق
هناك مناطق تم استهدافها هناك مناطق يجري
الان استهدافها وهناك مناطق لا يرغب الجيش
في استهدافها لذلك هذه قد تطول ربما فيها
مساله
الاشتباكات ومساله محاوله ابعاده منها
فالامر يشير بصوره واضحه الى ان هذا الامر
الحديث الان عن
اي جهه يمكن ان تميل فيها كفه هذه المعركه
سواء للجيش او
لدعم السريع او من له اليد العليا ربما
حتى الان في هذه المواجهه
ممكن ان اقول وفق المعطيات الموجوده بان
اليد العليا للجيش لطبيعه الاسلحه التي
يمتلكها الجيش بطبيعه انتشاره في كل
الولايات السودانيه لانه يسيطر على مثلا
يعني قاعده مروي وهي قاعده منها الطيران
الجوي على الانتشار الموجود العدد
الغالبيه له للجيش وليس للدعم السريع ولكن
اعداد الدعم السريع ايضا
كثيره هي عشرات الالاف ربما خالد قبل قليل
رايت فيديو
للجيش وهو
سعيد بانه في ولايه في مدينه نيالا هذا
الامر يؤكد ايضا ان هناك بعد اخر بان
يسيطر الجيش على ولايه دارفور لان ولايه
دارفور بصوره واضحه في الايام الماضيه
خلال هذه الاشتباكات كان يسيطر عليها
الدعم السريع لوجود بعد قبلي في هذا الامر
لوجود انتشار اكبر للدعم السريع
دخول الجيش الى نياله واعلانه انه الان
سيطره على هذه المدينه لهذا الامر ايضا
بعد اخر
سنتابع معكم هذه التغطيه نتابع ايضا هذه
المناشدات من طلبه جامعه الخرطوم
احنا طلاب
في حته تانيه ومعانا شخص
ما عندنا اموال
وايضا ناشد طفل سوداني الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع بووقف القتال المتواصل فورا خصوصا
الاشتباكات عده لفقدان احد اصدقائه
واحتجازه في نفس الوقت
وقتلوا اصحابي وكلهم يعني
قادر نرجع البيت ما عارف نعمل شنو جيت هنا
جيت ما عارف جيت ليه بيتناسب
اقسم بالله
الدهانات دهانات مش في البيوت والله والله
لان يعقوب مع استمرار الحرب الان اليوم
الرابع على التوالي
كيف يمكن النظر الى
مدى خطوره تداعيات هذه الحرب على الابعاد
الانسانيه يعني كما شاهدنا في الطفل قبل
قليل لاحد الطلاب بمناشدات ايضا في جامعه
الخرطوم والحديث عن ازمه في الغذاء
والدواء وازمه كذلك تعاني منها المستشفيات
اصلا السودان تعاني من مشاكل يعني قبل هذه
الحرب فبدات التاثير الان نعم خالد كلامك
صحيح اولا الحزن دعنا نتحدث عن جانب نفسي
وهو الحزن المترتب للاسر لفقدان
ابنائها بناتها ازواجها هناك فقد الان
لهذه الاسر لانها دانات اتت فجاه الامر
الاخر الان للمصابين كثير من المصابين لا
يستطيعون الان تلقي العلاج داخل
المستشفيات السودانيه اولا لازدحام هذه
المستشفيات ولقله الكادر الطبي
والمستلزمات
[موسيقى]
اذا الامر لديه تداعيات سياسيه عسكريه
اجتماعيه ونفسيه على المواطنين وكذلك هناك
بعد خارجي يتمثل في ان بعض هذه البعثات لم
تعد في امان
هذه صوره ايضا من زاويه اخرى تظهر كذلك
السنه
الدخان وهي تتصاعد ايضا في سماع العاصمه
الخرطوم
قوات الدعم السريع حسب هذه الاخبار
العاجله في الاتهامات الوارده في بيان
وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه الملفت كذلك
لينا في
البيان الجيش السوداني
الذي يعني عرضناه قبل قبل دقائق قال بانه
يستغرب الحديث عن هدنه مع حشد العدو قدره
او قوه في مروي لتامين هبوط طائرات
المساعدات عسكريه من جهه اقليم ماذا يحدث
في مروه يعني مع حقيقه الاوضاع اذا كانت
هناك من انباء تحدث ربما عن سيطره للقوات
الجيش على اكثر من مجهه
ما الذي يعتمد عليه الدعم السريع في مروي
للتامين هبوط هذه الطائره ان كان هذا
الامر صحيح
خالد الوضع في مروي ضبابه لا يستطيع احد
تاكيد الغلبه لمن لدينا مراسل وهو نزار
بقداوي الذي يمدنا بالاخبار بصوره مباشره
من هناك لكن كل الاخبار تشير الى اشتباكات
هناك قصف هناك اشتباكات تتم في قاعده مروي
اذا الغلبه حتى اللحظه غير معروفه لمن
وطالما ان الجيش في بيانه يتحدث بان الدعم
السريع يحشد فهذا يعني ان الدعم السريع
لديه وجود في هذه القاعده فهذا يعني ان
الغلبه لم تحسم والمعركه في مروي لم تحسن
بعد ومروي هي بدايه الصراع حينما حرك
الدعم السريع دبابات الى قاعده مروي وهي
قاعده جويه تتحرك منها الطائرات العسكريه
في السودان دخول دبابات الى هذا المكان
كان شراره الازمه لاعتبار ايضا الجيش بان
تحرك الدعم السريع الى هذه القاعده
تحديد هذا يعني انه يرغب في السيطره على
الطيران الجوي والسيطره على الطيران
بالمطار الخرطوم ربما مطار الخرطوم مطار
للطيران
العادي للخطوط
العالميه العاديه لكن ان يكون هناك مطار
عسكري وهو او قاعد عسكريه تتحرك منها
تحركات العسكريه التي لا يعلم بها طبعا
المواطنين لانها بعيده
وهي تتمركز فيها طائرات الجيش لذلك حينما
تحرك الدعم السريع الى هناك كان هذا مؤشر
له ابعاد استراتيجيه واعطى انطباع بان
التحركات الان هي ليست حديث سياسي
التحركات الان اصبحت على ارض الواقع
الليله ساعود اليك فقط اذكر ايضا بان
نيران المواجهات بين الجيش والدعم كذلك
طالت ممثليات دبلوماسيه غربيه ومقرات
امنيه في هذا السياق تعرض موكب دبلوماسيون
امريكي امس الاثنين لهجوم وفق ما كشف عنه
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه الذي اكد سلامه
الدبلوماسيين الوزيره اضافه بان التقارير
الاوليه تشير الى ان الهجوم على الموكب
نفدته عناصر مرتبطه بالدعم السريع لا يمكن
رفض استهداف الموكب ووصفه بالتصرف الطائش
وغير المسؤول وزير الخارجيه الامريكي كشف
بانه دعا الى وقف لاطلاق النار لمده 24
ساعه خلال اتصالين مع البرهان وحميدتي
وشرب لينك الى ان من شاني وقف لاطلاق
النار ان يشكل اساسا للعوده الى المفاوضات
لقد اجيت اتصالا هذا الصباح بكل من قائد
الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان والفريق محمد
دقلو حميدتي ودعوتهما لوقف اطلاق النار
لمده 24 ساعه فان وقف اطلاق النار من شانه
ان يشكل اساسا لعوده المفاوضات نتواصل مع
نظرائنا من الامارات والسعوديه وبريطانيا
بشان السودان لقد تعرضت قافله دبلوماسيه
امريكي امسي اطلاق نار في السودان لكن
جميع الافراد بخير وهذا التصرف طائش وغير
مسؤول
هذه التحركات لينا هذا الاتصال اتصال
الامريكي في ضوء تحركات كذلك اماراتيه
سعوديه تحركات مصريه كذلك افريقيه ايضا
الى اي مدى يمكن ان تؤثر اليوم على خط
المواجهه على خط هذه المعارك في ضوء يعني
مواقف الطرفين الدعم السريع الذي ارحب
بهذه الجهد او الهدنه لمده اربع انواع في
مقابل يعني اشارات بعدم الترحيب من قبل
الجيش على الاقل حتى الان لهذه الهدنه
لاعتبارات متعلقه بما يحدث على الارض من
تطورات نعم الطرفين اتفقا على هدنه لمده
ثلاثه ساعات لم يتم الالتزام بها الان
الجيش يعتبر انه هدنه الدعم السريعه التي
اعلنها عن 24 ساعه تشير الى انه في موقف
ضعيف بالتالي الجيش لا يرغب هذه
لتسجيل ربما بالضبط هذا هو خالد لذلك
لا يمكن الحديث عن وسطات على الاقل في
الوضع الحالي مؤثره يعني نعم لا نستطيع
الحديث عن وساطات مؤثره ان كانت المعارك
مشتده يعني كما يومها الاول ربما يكون
هناك
مجال ان تكون هذه الوساطات ناجحه بعض
الاحيان تاتي الردود على سبيل اننا
موافقون على سبيل طمانه المجتمع الدولي
ليس لتنفيذها انما لابداء حسن النوايا
وهذا يتضح بصوره واضحه حينما اعلن الطرفين
عن ابداء حسن النوايا وعن الهدنه ولم
يلتزم بها اذا هناك بعض الامور تتم للخارج
ليس لطمانه داخل السوداني انما لطمانه
المجتمع الدولي عندما يقول الجيش السوداني
بان العدو
يحشد قوه لتامين هبوط طائره مساعدات
عسكريه من جهه اقليم يعني ذلك بانه
بدات هذه الحرب تتخذ بعدا دوليا اقليميا
يمكن ان تتدخل فيه اطراف
اقليميه على مدى
يعني هذه الايام الاربعه ولا الايام
القادمه ايضا ومن هي هذه الجهه التي يمكن
ان تدخل في خط المواجهه الان من خلال
قراءتك ربما كان على الجيش ان يكشف من هي
هذه الجهات الاقليميه
وهل هي رساله حتى لا تتدخل الجهات
الاقليميه في هذا الامر ام ان هناك
معلومات حقيقيه عن بدء هذه الجهات
الاقليميه بالتدخل هذا امر يبدو ان للجيش
لديه معلومات حوله لا نملك حتى اللحظه اي
معلومات ولكن يبدو واضحا ان الجيش اما انه
يبعث برساله لمن اراد التدخل بان لا يتدخل
او انه ان هذه الجهات هي بدات فعليا
اتصالات وتتحرك في هذا الامر شكرا لك
مديره المكتب المكتب العربيه في الخطوه
اذا في اطار حرب البيانات المصوره نشر
الجيش السوداني على صفحته في تويتر مقطع
مصورا لسيطره جنوده على مقر القوات الدعم
السريع في شارع الغابه في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطه
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر هذا هو مغرهم الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله اكبر
في المقابل نشرت قوات الدعم السريع فيديو
لبعض جنودها قالت انه من داخل القياده
العامه في الخرطوم
القياده العامه
ابشر والله ابشر والله ابشر والله ابشر
الان داخل القياده العامه
والشباب منتصرين باذن الله واللي قدام ان
شاء الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر عشان الناس
سريع واذا الان الدعم سريع مسيطر على كل
الاوضاع داخل القياده
مبروك يا شباب مبروك مبروك مبروك
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا المحلل العسكري
للفريق فتح الرحمن محي الدين سيد فتح
الرحمن اهلا وسهلا بك معي اولا في هذا
اليوم اليوم الرابع
للحرب التي نشاهدها والمواجهات في العاصمه
الخرطوم كيف تقرا خريطه المعارك
والمواجهات وماذا يعني دخول مناطق لم تشهد
اشتباكات في ثلاثه ايام الماضيه في هذا
اليوم
يعني الان المسلحه يعني فرضت سيطرتها
كابله على مسرح
وتتعامل الامن في
تمشيط
مطارده
الافراد التمرد
في الوسط الاحياء السكنيه من وسط العاصمه
الخرطوم
هذه العمليه التي
نجد اننا يعني نشاهد
معارك في مناطق لم نشهدها من قبل لانه
القوات المسلحه بدات تنتشر بدات توسع من
دائره التامين في في الولايات الخرطوم
في اي المناطق التي تركز هذه المواجهات
سيد فتح الرحم
كان هنالك مواجهات تقريبا الحسنه الان
يعني استمرت لمده ساعتين يمكن
سواء لانه ايضا منطقه جبرا منطقه يعني
مكتظه بالسكان
تحتاج التعامل معها بحكمه ورويه والحمد
لله انا اعتقد انه الامر الحسن يعني
اصبحنا نسمع
بعد المسافه والاخرى يعني صوت طريقتين
ثلاثه كده يعني الشيخ خفيف يعني
ايضا في منطقه الشرق المطار ايضا هنالك
تعامل مع عناصر من المتمردين ايضا المنطقه
ماهوله بالسكان يتم التعامل فيها بحذر
المناطق المنطقه اللي حول القياده العامه
هي المنطقه الرئيسيه اللي فيها وجود الان
لقوات التمرد الجزء الجنوبي
عفوا الشمال الغربي من المطار الغربي من
مطار
شخصيات
مهمه في الدوله وهؤلاء للاسف يعني يحتجزون
عدد من الاسره في هذه المنطقه وبالتالي لا
تتعامل معهم وهم حتى الصوره التي ظهرت
ويقولون انها في القياده العامه قبل
الغريب هذه من المطار وليس اسمها القياده
العامه من هذا الجزء يذكره لك ويمكن يعني
صارت
البي اي بي ظاهره كانت في الصوره هم في
هذه المنطقه لانها متاخمه تماما او مجاوره
يعني يفصل ما بينهم سور فقط بين بين هذه
الموقع
المتخذها فبالتالي نزعل التعامل معه في
هذه المنطقه وسرعات المسلحه يعني التعامل
معهم
حتى تتمكن من تحرير ثم بعد ذلك التعامل
شكرا جزيلا لك المحل العسكري الفريق فتح
الرحمن محي الدين انضم الينا الان عضو
مجلس السياده الانتقال السوداني شمس الدين
كباشي سيد شمس مرحبا بك
الان
ما هو موقف الجيش من هذه الاشتباكات وفي
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
السلام عليكم اخي الكريم والتحيه لكل
منسوبيه قناه العربيه وسعيد بالحديث اليكم
في هذه الايام الصعبه من ايام السودان
اولا احنا عبركم نتاسف للشعب السوداني
للذي
وقع ما كنا نعمل التمضيه الامور الى هذا
لكن كل المؤشرات يعني
كانت تقول ذلك برغم الجهود الكثيره التي
بدلت وان كان من قوتها او اطراف السلام
املنا معهم كثيرا لتهدئه الامور ولكن لان
النيه كانت مبيضه اصلا لهذا
العمل فقط وقعنا في المحظور
عموما
القوات المسلحه كانت مضطره لدخول هذه
المعرفه وهي في تصريح واضح جدا من الفريق
اول محمد حمدان حميدي بانه يعمل على
اعتقال السيد الفريق اول البرهان وتسليمه
للعداله فهذا مستغرب يعني هو لازال يعرف
نفسه بنائب رئيس مجلس السياده ويريد ان
يعتقد رئيسه ويسلمه للعداله هذه
واحده نقوات الدعم السريع هي
القائد العام تتبع للقوات المسلحه بحكم
القانون
وتعتمر بامره اذن هذا تمرد واضح وبروس
قلقانون العسكري ان هذا التمرد العمل يقوم
به هو عمل
التمرد يصنف قانونا كذلك نحن ليست لدينا
مشكله مع قوات الدعم السريع في جزء كبير
جدا من عناصير من الضباط ووحدات كامله
يمكن نقلت من القوات المسلحه
عند انشائها
احنا نفصل ما بينما يقوم به
وشقيقي احنا الامور ستمضي وتاخذ وجهه
القانونيه
لكن سنعمل على توفيق اوضاع هذه
القوات
وعمل ترتيبات العسكريه اللازمه لذلك هو
تقييكم الان للوضع في
مقر القياده قياده الجيش القصر الجمهوري
في وسط الخرطوم في ضوء هذه الامباء التي
تتحدث عن معارك عنيفه بالاسلحه الثقيله
وحتى الطائره
نعم اول كل ما قرات الدعم السريع اذا في
الولايات يمكن تمت السيطره عليها تماما
بواسطه القوات المسلحه معسكرين صغيرين في
ولايه تحديدا في
منطقه اخرى وسيتم السيطره عليها ان شاء
الله
تلقرقوم تسمع الان صوت
الطلقات هذا
سريع على مقر قياده الجيش وعلى بيت
الضيافه وانت منذ ان بدا الهجوم هذا
هدفهما الاستراتيجي هو الاستيلاء
مقر
القياده وايضا بيت الضيافه والامور عندنا
مسيطره عليها تماما نحن نقدر الوضع انها
ان هذه حرب حرب حرب مدن وحرب المدن معقده
ولذلك نحن نتعامل معها وفقا لذلك الخرطوم
مختصه بالسكان وبالعمران ولذلك نحن نتعامل
مع هذه الحرب بحسابات دقيقه جدا حتى القوه
نحن نستخدمها بقدر بقدر ما نحتاجه الموقف
الذي امامنا صحيح ما استخدم الطيران
احيانا لضرب
بعض المقرات الذي لا زالت لديهم ايضا لقطع
خطوط
نعم هم منتشرون في
كثير داخل مدينه الخرطوم الكبرى او
العاصمه
السودانيه
ويمكن الان
قياده الدعم السريعيه فقدت السيطره على
فواتها تماما هذه القوات تقوم الان
باحتياز المدنيين والنهب والسلب وهذه كما
تعلم ويستخدمون حتى المواطنين
بشريه وهذه الجريمه القانون الوطني
والانسان وسنتعامل معها
المدفعي الذي نستمع اليه سيد شمس الدين
كذلك ربما الطلقات التي ظهرت قبل قليل من
اي المناطق تحديدا تاتي في الخرطوم
المقر سياده الجيش وكما ذكرت لك في الاول
ان هدفهم هو قياده الجيش فهذه الطلقات هي
على مقر ااا قياده الجيش وتنطلق من اتجاه
الجنوب اضيف اليك انهم ايضا خربوا المطار
اوقفوا ابطلوا اجهزه الملاحه
اطابوا عدد من الطائرات في مطار الخرطوم
الدولي وهذا ايضا سنتجه اليه
قانونيا بالاضافه للجنود الدروع البشريه
التي
يستخدمون المواطنين
مستهدف من قبل قوات الجيش من خلال هذا
القسط او غيره سيد شمس الدين
قياده الجيش
ولم يعني نخرج بعد لمطارده حمايه او او
غيره نحن نعلم وندري ونقيم
متى ننتشر داخل المدينه يمكن البعض دخول
الدعم منتشر بشكل واسع
يعني كان جزءا من
الصحيح لكن نحن نعلم ولكل شيء ميقاته لكل
شيء مقداره
لماذا المواطنون الان السودانيون يقولون
بان عربات الدعم السريعيه التي تنتشر
بكثافه الان في شوارع العاصمه
الخرطوم في مقابل ايضا تصريحاتكم بان هناك
انتشار ربما متواتر لقوات الجيش في اكثر
من مكان في العاصمه السودانيه سيد شمس
الدين
يعني قياده الدعم السريع هي فاقد السيطره
على قواتها الان هم يعيطون
حتى لا اخلاقي يدخلون البيوت بدون اذونات
بدون اذن اهلها ويسرقون ويفعلون حتى
تعذبوا بالامس على السفاره
الامريكيه واصدرت بيان بذلك قبلها ايضا
السفاره الفرنسيه تمت اصابه فاجرهم وحشيه
ولا يعني
غير
مقبوله يمكن
ربما
اسبابهم ولكن ان شاء الله كل الامور ستوضع
في نصابها باسرع ما يمكن ان شاء الله هل
هناك وسطات جلال سيد شمس الدين كبيش او
سابقا لا لا
الذي حدث بالنسبه الينا هو تمرد عسكري
عسكري لكن الذي يجري الان ونتفاهم به
نتفاهم فيه يمكن هنالك مقترح يمكن تم
تقديمه لنا من المنظمه الامميه وايضا
باتصالات من الدول شقيقه
الخارجيه الامريكي
بوقف اطلاق النار لمده 24
ساعه نحن وافقنا على ذلك لمده 24 ساعه فقط
لماذا نظرا للظروف الانسانيه القاتله التي
يعيشها مواطنه الخرطوم التحركات اصبحت
صعبه المستشفيات والخدمات في الكهرباء
والمياه نحتاج لهذه ال 24 ساعه
لسماح للمواطنين بالحركه
والجهات الحكوميه المسؤوله بتامين
الاحتياجات
اللازمه لكن الامر ليس وفاء اولا نقبل اي
وساطه في هذا الامر هو شان عسكري وحتى هو
ليس بالشان
السياسي وفي التصنيف العسكري هو التمرد
وسنتعامل معه وفق القانون الكثير من
السودانيين يسالون عن السيد عبد الفتاح
البرهان ويتساءلون عن عدم ظهور ظهور او في
اي خطاب مصور موجه للسوداني
البرهان موجود وهو بخير وفي صحه جيده
الاطلال عبر الفيديوهات لو كنت متابع يمكن
قبل يومين كان في مقر قياده الجيش وهناك
في فيديو متداول بالامس كان له تصريحات
كهذه لقناه سكاي نيوز
الانجليزيه وهو موجود وهو الذي يدير هذه
المعركه مع هؤلاء المتواجدين
هل هل رفض الجيش السوداني
الهدنه بموقفه بان اي هدنه ستحاول من
خلالها قوات الدعم السريع التغطيه على
هزيمتها كما جاء في بيان الجيش
نحن بنذكر ذلك نحن
الهدنه الموقوته هم طرفوا 24 ساعه ونحن
وافقنا عليها ولكن اشترطنا شرطا معين وهذا
الدعم السريع لن تلتزم بهذه الهدنه عطفا
على تجارب خلال الايام السابقه يمكن
بالامس ايضا
بالتشاور مع المبعوثه الامم اتفقنا على هن
لمده اربع ساعات ولكن مع بدايه
الهدنه يعني يمكن الهدنه كانت مواقعنا
ومقراتنا الجيش
تتم مهاجمتها
تشاورنا
والترقو
ها
نلتزم بضبط
هذه القوات المسلحه المعروفه يعني
وبقوانينه وبلاواحيها فؤاد منضبطه ليست
كالقوات المتمرده فقلنا لهم اضمنوا انتم
ان الدعم السريع
بذلك
ونحن ان شاء الله وفق التوقيت الذي سيتفق
عليه واظنه من السادس مساء اليوم 24 ساعه
سنلتزم بذلك ونرى ماذا ستفعل كانت الدعم
اذا ضبط والسيطره على قواتها ما الذي جرى
في اتصال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي بالسيد
عبد الفتاح البرهان
حول هذه النقطه تحديدا ان الوضع الانساني
والقدمي
يستدعي
التوقف لمده 24 ساعه
يؤدي الى
الضربه الصحي والخدمي الكهرباء المياه
وايضا المتعلقه بالصحه طبعا نحن معه نحن
معنيين بالمواطن لذلك قبلنا
هذاك المقترحات كل الحوار على ما اعتقد
كان دائما هؤلاء حول هذه النقطه في بيان
ايضا الجيش السوداني يتحدث على ان
قوه دعم تابعه للعدو كما جاء في هذا
البيان تستعد لاستقبال الطائرات مساعدات
من جهات اقليميه في مروي فذلك صحيح
يقدم او يجري لتقديمه لقوات الدعم السريع
من دولتين
تجاوران السودان احدى هذه الدول في الغرب
وبالفعل امس بالامس نزلت طيارتين في موقع
ما ونقلت الذخائر
المواد الامداد الاخرى الى منطقه اخرى
محاوله ايضا لانزال
طائره ايضا محمله بالزخائير والانذار
لانزالها في مطار مرعبه هذه المعلومات
صحيحه ودقيقه ونحن
يعني تكون بعض الدول
وان كانت تقوم به جماعات ليست تحت سيطره
لكن تبقى الدوله شيء بشكل او باخر عن
مسؤوليه مواطنيها حتى ان كانوا متمردين
كيف لهذه الطائرات تنتهبط في مروي يعني ما
هو الوضع الان من يسيطر على المطار على
القاعده في هذه المنطقه
الطائرات لم تحبط في في في
مروي لكن هنالك محاولات من قوات الدعم
السريع لتحيه الظروف اللازمه لانزال هذه
الطائره اما الطائرتين الاخرتين الذين
تحدثت عنهما فقط نزلتها في منطقه حدوديه
مجاوره للسودان خارج اراضي السودان ونقلت
الى موقع ما داخل الاراضي السوداني ما هي
الاستراتيجيه العسكريه التي يعتمد الان
عليها الجيش في حرب المدن والشوارع التي
ربما ربما كما يرى البعض من الخبراء
العسكريين
ان للدعم السريع
افضليه خاصه في ضوء القدره على التحرك
السريع في ارجاء متعدده من العاصمه
الخرطوم مركز المعارك الرئيسي لها
نحن يعني نقدر
يقدمه الخبراء العسكريون في القنوات
المختلفه ولكن نقول لهم نحن في مركز
القياده
ونعلم تمام ما نقوم
به ولكل حادث حديث ان شاء الله كيف
تتعاملون مع الاوضاع الانسانيه الصعبه
الان التي من من ازمه للمياه من ضغط على
المستشفيات من خروج عدد منها يعني عن
الخدمه
وايضا على مستوى مجلس السياده ومجلس
الوزراء وايضا اضيف لك
لان قوات الدعم السريع تحتجز الفنيين
والمهندسين تحديدا في محطه
بحري للمياه حتى لا تنسى مثل هذه الخدمه
الحيويه للمواطنين وايضا في اماكن
اخرى نحن جيد وسنبذل
كل ما يمكن
ان نسهل الامر مواطنينا باذن الله
قبل ساعه تقريبا كان هناك قصف لمنطقه كان
مراسل العربيه بانها منطقه محيطه بالقياده
العامه بجانب جسر المسلميه بعد ذلك مباشره
ظهرت تصريحات بان هناك من يستغل بعض
المباني والمستشفيات كقاعده ارتكاز عسكريه
هل
هي تحتمل بالمباني وتدخل
البيوت وهناك
يسمى حي المطار للمطار وجنوب مركز قياده
الجيش كان يبطله كبار الموظفين بالدوله
هذا
الدعم السريع يعني تنطلق منه
وتحتمي بعد ان اخرجت المواطنين عنوه هذه
جريمه تضاف لجرائمهم جريمه ضد الانساني
انت تؤكد سيدي بان الهدنه
وافقتم عليها وستبدا في الساعه السادسه
مساء هذا اليوم ولمده 24 ساعه
نعم نحن حاضرون تماما لتنفيذ هذه
الهدنه اعتبارا من الساعه الثابته اساس
السادسه وقت النفاذة وطبعا الهدنه لا تعني
فقط وقفه اطلاق النار
تعني وقف التحركات العسكريه وفق الامدادات
في الداخل
وبالخارج الوطنيه مستنكره وهي مدارنه
وكثير وكثير من الاجراءات على كل نحن ان
شاء الله سنلتزم بهذه الهدنه وسنراقب
وهنالك لجنه ايضا مشكله
من من مدينه
للمراقبه
والتقييم خلال هذه الاطراف التي تتواصلون
معها الان لتثبيت هذه الهدنه السيد شمس
الدين
نحن نتواصل مع البيت الامميه الموجوده
نتواصل مع
اليهوديه كلها نتواصل مع بعض
بصراحه
الفرنسيه وكثيرين وبعض الدول العربيه
الشقيقه التي
مهتمه يعني بالشام السودان ويقلقها الذي
يجري يمكن السعوديه
الجمهوريه مصر الشقيقه وجنوب السودان كلهم
يحسون على هذا الوقت
الموقود لمده 24 ساعه فقط حتى
الخدمات والممرات الانسانيه فهي حقيقه بعض
الفيديوهات التي تظهر عن وجود انشقاقات
داخل مؤسسه الجيش السوداني او اخرى ايضا
تعرض عن انشقاقات الداخل قوات الدعم
السريعه
لدينا داخل الق
وات وليس هنالك ما يدعون الى
الانشقاق بل هذا الموقف يريد القوات
المسلحه
تماسكا وقوه ونحن جميعنا نعمل تحت امره
القائد العام الانشقاقات في قوات الدعم
السريع صحيحه 100%
هنالك الكثير من
القوات المسلحه او الشرطه او
كثيرون من الضباب اعلنوا صراحه عبر
الوسائل
المختلفه انهم لم يمضوا في هذه الحرب
العائليه
وينضموا الى القوات المسلحه او او الى
الاجهزه
وهذه معلومه صحيحه هل هناك تحركات داخليه
سودانيه الان على اتصال انتم معها في
محاولات ربما لوقف هذا القتال الان وهل
هناك اي تحركات او اتصالات تجري مع اطراف
اخرى خارجيه مصر السعوديه الامارات الدول
الافريقيه او غيرها
نعم الاطراف السودانيه يعني ابدا لم تتوقف
يعني انا احيي في هذه المناسبه كل القوى
السياسيه بمختلف الوانه واحيي كذلك الاخوه
بقيادات الحركات المسلحه
جميع قلب يعني يمكن
ازمه واحده الناس يعني الوضع الانساني
والخدمي في البلاد لذلك
مناسباتهم سبقت المناسبات الاماميه وغيرها
وقلقين وهم يعملون معنا على التواصل
وثيق وايضا اضيف اليك ان يعني جهودا كثيره
يعني بذلت من قوه السياسيه ومن اطراف
الكفاح
المسلحه حتى يعني لا نصلي مرحله المواجهه
التي
نعيشها الان فالشكر لهم على جهودهم
السابقه وعلى جهودهم الحاليه ففي الوطن
نلتقي جميعا
شكرا جزيلا لك شمس الدين كباش عضو مجلس
السياده الانتقال السوداني
وسط روايات متضاربه ايضا من الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريعه افادت
الاخيره بانها سيطرت على مطار الخرطوم
الدولي في العاصمه السودانيه معا اندلاع
اشتباكات مع الجيش
[تصفيق]
الان بمطار
الخرطوم المدني
صواريخ عرقل اه نفسي
صور ملتقطه بالاقمار الصناعيه تظهر حجم
الدمار الذي لحق بمطاري الخرطوم او مروي
وتعرض صور مشاهد للطائرات مدنيه وعسكريه
مدمره بالاضافه الى لقطات لاعمده النيران
الناجمه عن الحرائق
مطارات السودان اذا كانت ساحه معارك مبكره
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في هذا
العرض نتعرف على ابرز مطارات البلاد التي
تدور فيها وحولها المعركه
اهميه استراتيجيه تحظى بها المطارات في اي
نزاع مسلح والوضع في السودان ليس استثناء
لهذه الاهميه في قلب الخرطوم يقع مطار
العاصمه وهو الاكبر في السودان انشئ
المطار عام
1947 ومر بعده عمليات توسعه واعاده تاهيل
حتى بات مركزا ل 95% من حركه الطيران
الخارجيه في الاشتباكات الحاليه في
السودان كان مطار الخرطوم محور رئيسيا
للاقتتال بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع خاصه وان المطار مدني وترتبط به
قاعده عسكريه جويه
اهميه اخرى يحظى بها مطار الابيض في
المدينه التي تحمل ذات الاسم على بعد 450
كيلومترا غرب الخرطوم فالمطار نقطه وصل
بين العاصمه ومعظم مناطق دارفور كما انه
مركز لقوات حفظ السلام الامميه في منطقه
ابياي المتنازع عليها بين السودان ودوله
جنوب السودان
اخيرا الى مطار مروي الواقع في الولايات
الشماليه وتتداخل فيه الاهميه الاقتصاديه
بالعسكريه هذا المطار كان من المشاريع
المصاحبه لانشاء خزان او سد مروي للاهميه
في الري وتوليد الكهرباء وكما هو الحال
بالنسبه لمطار الخرطوم يحتوي مطار مروي
بدوره على قاعده جويه
حسب اخر الاخبار ايضا
السيد عبد الفتاح البرهان رئيس مجلس
السياده السوداني في تصريحات للسي ان ان
قال بنوافق على هدنه ل 24 ساعه تبدا
السادسه مساء وسيلتزم بها على خط الازمه
ايضا دخلت مصر الدوله المجاوره للسودان
واعلن المتحدث باسم رئاسه الجمهوريه
المصريه للرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي اجتمع
بالمجلس الاعلى للقوات المسلحه المصريه
افاده او افادت مراسله العربيه في القاهره
ان الاجتماع يبحث وضع الجنود المصريين
المحتجزين لدى قوات الدعم السريع في
السودان اضافه الى تقييم شامل للاوضاع في
السودان واكدت مصادر العربيه ان القاهره
تعمل على التوصل لهدله قبل عيد الفطر
ايضا في مصر عبر مواطنون سودانيون عن
غضبهم وحزنهم لاستمرار المواجهات الداميه
بين قوات الجيش والدعم السريع وطالبوا
بضروره وقف سريع لاطلاق النار والاستجابه
الفوريه لجميع مبادره التهدئه
هنا في حاره الصوفي في احدى ضواحي منطقه
وسط البلد في العاصمه القاهره تعكس ملامح
وجوه ابناء الجاليه السودانيه علامات حزن
واسى العيون تتوجه لشاشات التلفاز
والهواتف النقاله لمتابعه اخبار
الاشتباكات الداميه في السودان والحديث لا
يتوقف عن مجريات القتل والخراب والله
وقفوا حرف الدنيا رمضان يعني في حد في
رمضان بحارب يوقف حرب الناس دي مساكين ما
فيش كهرباء ما فيش مويه يعني احنا ما
واقفين مع الجيش ولا واقفين مع حماتي نحن
عايزين نحد اللحم السودان والسودان يد
واحده اغلب من التقيناهم لم يخفوا حزنهم
وغضبهم الجميع يحاول ان يتواصل مع الاهل
والاقارب للاطمئنان على سلامتهم
يعني مش عايزين مش قادرين يعني ما قادرين
ينوموا حتى
بس ربنا يكون في عونه ان شاء الله يا رب
الكثيرون عبروا عن املهم في ان تنجح
المناشدات والمحاولات العربيه والاقليميه
والدوليه للوصول الى وقف لاطلاق النار
والحد من نزيف الدماء نتمنى من اخواننا
العرب المنطقه الجاليه العربيه كل ما
يجفهم معنا في كل شيء ان شاء الله يا رب
العالمين نرجح كل المجتمع الدولي
والاقليمي
تقف وقفه واحده اتجاه خروج من الازمه
الحاليه هسه حاليا قاعد في الخرطوم
الاحداث وتداعياتها اثرت على مجموعات
كبيره من السودانيين والمصريين العاملين
في مجالات النقد البري بين البلدين شغل
بتاعنا الضرر من 3 ايام بالضبط او من اربع
ايام الوضع اختلف انا جاري سواق مثلا
ومعايا عربيه ومعايا واحد صاحبي معي عربيه
بنشيل شغل بنودي شغل الشغل بقى له اربع
ايام عدد ابناء الجاليه السودانيه في مصر
يتراوح ما بين خمسه الى ثمانيه ملايين
نسمه رقم مرشح للزياده في حال استمرار ت
دهور الاوضاع السياسيه والامنيه
والاقتصاديه احمد عثمان العربيه القاهره
من القاهره تنضم الينا الصحفيه المختصه في
الشان الافريقي صباح موسى سيد صباح اهلا
وسهلا بك سيدنا مرحبا معنا في هذه التغطيه
كيف تتابع الان القاهره ما يحدث من تطورات
في السودان
القاهره الان يعني تتابع عن كسب ما يحدث
في السودان منذ يعني البدايات ومن بدايه
اندلاع المواجهات العسكريه بين الجيش وقوه
الدعم السريع مصر تتابع عن كسب
تخشى كثيرا عن تدهور الاوضاع في السودان
هناك يعني اجتماعات واتصالات كان اخر هذه
الاجتماعات اجتماع المجلس الاعلى للقوات
المسلحه هذا المجلس ينعقد اوقات
اتخاذ قرارات
اهميه داخل الداخل المصري حينما ينعقد
للاوضاع في السودان مؤشر انه فعلا الاوضاع
في السودان تتجه
نحو منحدر خطير لذلك انعقد المجلس بالامس
بقياده الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي مصر يعني
تحاول بكل الطرق والاتصالات الدبلوماسيه
مع اشقاء واصدقاء السودان واتصالات حتى
داخل السودان يعني لوقف او القتال
وتحاول ان تسعى لمبادره يعني لوقف القتال
قبل العيد الفطر المبارك هي تسعى بكل
الطرق في كل الاتجاهات مع جنوب السودان
ايضا كان هناك اتصال بين الرئيس عبد
الفتاح السيسي والرئيس سلفا كيرميار
الاثنين لديهما علاقات جيده مع
قطبي الصراع في الخرطوم عبد الفتاح
البرهان
وحميدتي وبالتالي مصر الان تراقب بحذر
شديد لانه الاوضاع في السودان بالتاكيد
لدي انعكاسات مباشره وواضحه على مصر وعلى
امنها القومي ولذلك هناك تحركات على كل
الاصعده لوقف على الاقل اطلاق النار في
هذا التوقيت قبل ان تندلع
اكثر من هذا في السودان
السيد عمرو موسى الامين العام السابق
للجامعه العربيه قال لبعض المصالح العربيه
في تغريده على تويتر قد تتعارض مع المصالح
المصريه الاكثر عمقا في السودان كذلك
الحال في افريقيا هنا
يتوقع من مصر وقفه صريحه وجريئه اذ ان
مصالحنا كما يقول الحيويه في هذه المنطقه
باسرها اصبحت مهدده وعلى المحك ماذا قصد
عمر موسى برايك من هذه التغريد بقراءته
لما يحدث
وبماذا يطالب بالتاكيد نعم بالتاكيد
السودان مهم جدا
للدول في الدول لبعض الدول العربيه والدول
في الاقليم لكن على وجه الخصوص السودان هو
بالفعل عمق امني واستراتيجي لمصر وبالتالي
حديث السيد عمرو موسى تحذير في المقام
الاول بان مصر
يقع عليها عبء اكثر من اي دوله بعيده حتى
لو كانت بعد الدول العربيه تحاول ان تعمل
على استقرار في السودان ولكن من منطلق
مصالح مصر لديها مصالح ولديها عمق امني
واستراتيجي في السودان لدينا حدود مشتركه
مع السودان العلاقه مع السودان تختلف معك
عن كل دول العالم دولتين يعني يعني
مصيرهما واحد شعبهما واحد وبالتالي يحذر
من ان تكون التدخلات يعني تدخلات ده هو لا
يعني يطالب بتحييد بعض الدول في عدم
التدخل يطالب بان لكل مصر دور اكبر في هذه
المرحله في المرحله السياسيه كانت مصر
تتدخل على استحياء كان المجتمع الدولي على
مستوى الرباعيه وعلى ثلاثيه يتدخل في
الشان السوداني
للمبادرات السلميه مصر عندما استشعرت في
الاخير بالخطر استقرات بالفعل
استراتيجيا ان السودان من الممكن مع
الخلافات المدنيه المدنيه ان ينزلق الى
هذا الاشتباك الذي نحن بصدده الان ولذلك
تدخلت في الفترات الاخيره للم الشتات
السوداني بكل المكونات المدنيه ودعت الى
طاوله حوار موحده لكل القوى السياسيه في
السودان اعتقد ان مصر في هذا التوقيت
والورشه التي اعلنتها في القاهره كانت
تستقرئ ان هذا الخلاف المدني المدني ربما
يعرض البلاد
توقع اي تحرك مكون العسكري من قبل مصر
يعني تتجاوز ربما الاطار السياسي
والدبلوماسي خاصه في ضوء ما قاله قبل قليل
السيد شمس الدين كباشي
باتهامات بناء على معلومات كما قال
بمساعدات عسكريه من دولتين على الحدود
السودانيه الغربيه من هنا مصر الى اي مدى
يمكن ان تتحرك في هذا الاطار العسكريا
سريعا
مخرجات مجلس الاعلى للقوات المسلحه بالامس
كان الرئيس يتحدث عن عدم التدخل في الشان
السوداني مصر لا يمكن ان تتدخل في شؤون اي
دوله ولكن هو هناك مساعد دبلوماسيه مصر لا
يمكن ان تتدخل لطرف على حساب طرف في
السودان برغم اهميه السودان بالنسبه لمصر
لكن مصر دوله كبيره لا تستطيع ان تدخل
بهذا الشكل لكنها لن تتوقف عن المساعي
والجهود الدبلوماسيه لوقف نزيهه الدم
الموجود في الخرطوم الان وليس ذلك معناه
تدخل عسكريا شكرا جزيلا لك الصحفيه
المختصه في شان الافريقي صباح موسى
اذن نهايه هذه الساعه تغطيتنا ما زالت
مستمره
زميل احمد الهادي سيصحبكم ايضا في المزيد
حول التطورات الاوضاع في السودان على راس
السنه الى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات